on va pas se mentir
ce n'est pas une équipe de foot lettres
des quiches toi tu henrich doigts thank
you vous êtes tous sans exception des
quiches
mais on va essayer vous qualifier pour
la coupe
et pour ça il faut avoir la gagne
tu peux me dire ce que c'est que la
gagne voilà picasso c'est quoi la guerre
c'était de gagner
toi la gagne c'est quoi ben c'est le
contraire de perdre ok merci einstein
c'est une terre où on t'écoute la gaine
c'est la négation qui fait un sportif se
surpasser pour l'emporter
rien à voir
la gagne c'est ce qui fait que tu fais
tout ce que tu peux pour gagner
donc en fait c'est exactement ce qui
veut dire quoi non non une confiance
il ya une petite nuance